Hey,
but is,
I mean ultimately is it making people happier right now?
Most technology I would say no.
In fact,
you and I were talking about social media before this about just not having
Instagram on your phone and not dealing with it.
You feel better.
Yes.
I think that one of the issues with social media,
it's been pointed out by many people.
Is that right?
MMM.
I think maybe particularly Instagram.
Um,
people look like they have a much better life than they really do,
right?
By design.
Yeah.
People are posting pictures of when they were really happy,
they're modifying those pictures to be better looking in with,
they're not modifying the pictures there.
At least selecting the pictures for the best lighting,
the best angle.
Um,
so people basically seem
they're way better looking than they basically really are.
Right.
Um,
and they're way happier seeming than they really are.
So if you look at everyone on Instagram,
you might think,
man,
there are all these happy,
beautiful people and I'm not that good looking and I'm not happy,
so I must suck,
you know,
and that's going to make feel sad.
So when in fact those people you think are super happy,
actually not that happy.
Some of them are really depressed.
They're very sad.
Okay.
So I'm the happiest Syrian people actually some of the saddest people in
reality.
Um,
and,
and nobody looks good all the time.
Doesn't matter who you are.
No,
it's not even something you should want.
What do you want to look great.
All the time.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
uh,
so I think,
I think things like that can make people quite sad just just by comparison.
Cause you,
you just sort of,
you know,
people,
people generally think of themselves relative to two others.
It's,
it's uh,
we're constantly re we baselining our expectations.
MMM.
And you can see this,
say if you watch some show like naked and afraid or if you just go and try
living in the woods by yourself for a while and you'll like
go learn that civilization was quite great.
Has Lots,
a lot of it is people want to come back civilization pretty fast on naked and
afraid.
Wasn't that a Thoreau quote?
The comparison's,
the thief of joy
of happiness is reality minus expectations.
That's great too,
but the comparison is the thief of joy really holds true to peep.
Is it date or Roosevelt?
Roosevelt.
Fascinating.
Um,
and when you think about Instagram,
because would essentially Instagram is with a lot of people is you're giving
them the opportunity to be their own PR agent and they always go towards the
glamorous,
you know,
and when any anybody does show,
Hashtag no filter I have,
they have,
they really do do that.
Like,
oh,
you're so brave.
Lucky you don't make up.
No.
Yeah,
they look good anyway.
You look great.
We doing,
oh my God,
you don't have makeup on still a cottage.
Fuck.
Do you know what you're doing?
I know what you're doing too.
They're there.
They're letting you know.
And then the feeding off that comment section.
Ooh,
just little kits sitting there like,
look,
it's a fresh stream of love.
Like you're getting right up to the source as it comes out of the earth and
you're sucking that water.
Emojis.
Yeah.
Literally my,
what my concern is not so much what Instagram is,
is that I didn't think that people had the need for this or the expectation for
some sort of technology that allows them to constantly get love and adulation
from strangers and comments and this ability to project this sort of distorted
version of who you really are.
But I worry about where it goes.
Like what's the next one?
What's the next one?
Like where is it?
Is it going to be augmented to some sort of a weird augmented or virtual sort of
Instagram type situation where you're not going to want to live in this real
world.
You're going to want to interface with this sort of world that you've created
through your social media page and some next level thing.
Go live in the simulation.
Yeah,
maybe some ready player one type shit that's real.
That seems we have that HTC Vive here and I've only done it a couple of times
quite honestly cause it kind of freaks me out.
My kids fucking love it man.
They love it.
They love playing these Weirdo Games and and walking around with that headset
on.
But pardon me?
Watching them do it goes,
wow.
I wonder if this is like the precursor,
just sort of like if you look at that phone,
that Gordon Gekko hat on the beach and then you compare that Alpha,
yeah.
You pair that to like a galaxy note nine I how the fuck did that become that?
Right.
And I wonder when I see this HTC vibe and like what is that thing going to be 10
years from now when we're making fun of what it is now?
What is it,
how,
I mean how ingrained and how,
how connected and interconnected is this technology going to be in our life?
Yeah.
Will be
at some point indistinguishable from reality
where we'll lose this.
We're lose this.
Like you and I are just looking at show through our eyes.
Hi.
See you when you see me I think,
I hope you think so.
I think you probably have brought up regularize.
This could be some simulation.
It could.
Do you entertain that?
Well,
the argument for the simulation I think is quite strong because if you assume
any improvements at all over time and improvement,
1% 0.1% just extend the timeframe,
make it a thousand years and million years.
The Universe is 13.8 billion years old.
Okay,
what would it w w civilization if you counted,
if you're very generous,
civilization is maybe seven or 8,000 years old.
If you count it from the first writing,
this is nothing.
This says nothing.
Um,
so if you assume any rate of improvement at all,
then games will be indistinguishable from reality
or civilization will end one of those two things will occur.
Oh four we are most likely in a simulation or we're on our way to one.
Right?
Well it's just we could most certainly be on the road.
We could be on the road to that,
right?
It doesn't mean that it has to have her be in base reality.
It could be in base reality.
We could be here now on our way to the road or on her way to the destination
where this can never happen again.
Where we are completely ingrained in some sort of an artificial technology or
some sort of a symbiotic relationship with the internet or the next level of
sharing information,
but right now we're not there yet.
That's possible too.
Right?
It's possible that a simulation is one day going to be inevitable that we're
going to have something that's indistinguishable from regular reality,
but maybe we're not there yet.
That's also possible
when you're not quite there yet.
That this is real.
When I touched that feels very real.
Maybe that's why everybody's like getting to like mason jars and shit.
Mason suede shoes.
People are to like craft restaurants and they wouldn't want raw wood.
Everyone says everyone not to see metal people.
It seems like people are like longing towards some weird log cabin type
nostalgia reality.
Yeah,
like holding on like Klingon to start dragging their nails through the mud.
Like don't take me a yes,
I want to walk.
But then,
but then people will go get a mason jar with a wine stem or a handle
that's dark makes me lose faith in humanity.
Wine,
stem and a handle.
They have those.
Oh,
the sturdy people.
That's just assholes.
That's like people make pet rocks rough.
Right.
This is,
some people are just assholes.
They take advantage of our generous nature.
It was made with the Weinstein I made with Andell.
They made it that way.
So the,
the one on to the Macy's.
Ah,
you felt that would be fine if there was like glued it on or something.
Right.
It was made that way.
White trash sheet.
Oh this is disgusting.
It is right there.
Yup.
This is terrible.
Yeah.
That's like fake breasts that are designed to be hard like fake breasts from the
60s.
It's like if you really long for the ones with ripples,
here we go.
Yeah.
That's almost what that is.
What are you going to do man?
This is not nothing,
you know,
it's not,
you can do stop certain terrible ideas from propagating.
Yeah.
Um,
anyway,
I,
I don't want to sound like,
like thanks for two dark cause I think like you kind of have to
be optimistic about the future.
There's no point in being pessimistic.
It's just negative.
It doesn't help,
you know,
I think you want to be,
I mean,
my theory is like you'd rather be optimistic.
I think I'd rather be optimistic and wrong than pessimistic and right,
right.
At least we're on that side.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause if you're pessimistic is going to be as this rule.
Nobody wants to be around you anyway.
If it's the end of the world,
you know,
like a fucking told you bro.
Yeah.
The world's ending.
It is way less Raul.
I mean enjoy the journey,
right?
If you really want to get morose,
I mean it is what it is for all of us anyway.
We were all going to go unless some something changes.
Yeah.
I mean ultimately,
you know,
even if we just sort of existed as humans forever,
we'd be,
we'd still eventually,
that'd be like the heat death of the universe.
Right?
Your years from now,
if we get a pass the sun,
if we figured out a way past the son running out of juice,
eventually it's going to end.
It's just a question of when.
Right.
So it really,
it's all about the journey
or transcendence from whatever we are now into something that doesn't worry
about death.
Okay.
The universe as we know,
it will dissipate into a fine mist of cold,
nothing.
This eventually,
and then someone's going to bottle it and put a fragrance to it,
sell it to French people and another dimension.
It's just a very long time.
So I think it's really just about how can we make it last longer.
Are you a proponent of the multiuniverse theory?
Do you believe that there are many,
many universes and that even if this one fades out,
that there's other ones that are starting fresh right now and if there's an
infinite number of them,
they're just constantly and just never ending cycle of birth and death?
I think most likely,
this is just about probability.
There are many,
many simulations,
these simulations or we might as well call them reality or you could call them
the multiverse.
These simulations you believe are created like someone has managed running on
the substrate,
so that substrate is probably boring.
Boring.
How so?
Well when we create a simulation like a game or a movie,
it's the distillation of what's interesting about life.
You know like it,
it takes,
could take a year to shoot an action movie and then that's all distilled down
into two or three hours.
So let me tell you,
if you see an action movie being filmed,
frigging boring,
super boring takes,
there's like lots of takes those,
everything's in a green screen,
looks pretty goofy,
it doesn't look cool.
But once you add the CGI and have great editing,
it's amazing.
So I think most likely
if we're a simulation,
it's really boring outside the simulation
because why would you make simulation that's boring cause make simulation way
more interesting in the base reality that is if this right now is a simulation.
Yes.
And ultimately,
inevitably we're,
if as long as we don't die or get hit by a media,
we're going to create some sort of simulation.
If we continue on the same technological path we're on,
we're on right now.
Yes.
But we might not be there yet.
So it might not be a simulation here,
but it most likely is you feel other places,
this notion of place or where is is a flawed yes.
Flawed version.
If he has this sort of
that a vive,
which that's made by valve and steam and H it's really valve that made it,
HTC did the hardware but it's really a valve thing.
Um,
makers of halflife.
Yes.
Huh.
Wow.
Have Great Company,
Great Company.
Um
hmm.
Uh,
when you're in that,
in that sense,
in that virtual reality,
which is only going to get better,
where are you?
Where are you really?
Right?
You aren't anywhere.
Well,
whereas in the computer,
what w what defines where you are exactly right.
It's your perception.
Is it your perceptions or is it,
you know,
a scale that we have under your butt.
You right here,
I've measured you.
You're the same weight as you were when you left,
but you meanwhile your experience,
why do you think you're where you are right now?
You might not be,
I'll spark up joining.
If you keep talking to your manager is going to come in here.
We might have to lock the door right now.
You think you're in a studio in la?
That's what I heard.
You might be in a computer.
Oh listen man,
I think about this all the time.
Yeah.
I mean it's unquestionable that one day that'll be the case.
As long as we keep going,
as long as nothing interrupts us.
And if we start from scratch and you know,
we're single celled organisms all over again and then millions and millions of
years later would become the next thing that is us with creativity and the
ability to change the environment.
It's going to keep monkeying with things until it figures out a way to change
reality to change.
I mean almost like punch a hole through what is this thing into what,
what it wants it to be and create new things.
And then those new things will intersect with other people's do things.
And then there'll be this ultimate pathway of infinite ideas and expression all
through technology.
Yeah.
And then we're wondering,
we're going to wonder like why are we here?
What are we doing?
Let's find out.
I mean,
I think we should take the actions,
the set of actions that are most likely to make the future better.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
And then reevaluate those actions to make sure they're there.
That it's true.
Why.